bonjour Mathieu d'Arnaud bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de l'Ardèche mon du groupe les
républicains on va parler de la
protection des élus des violences c'est
un sujet que vous suivez
particulièrement au Sénat mais d'abord
dans l'actualité encore et toujours la
réforme des retraites Emmanuel Macron ce
matin dans l'opinion réaffirme la
nécessité de cette réforme Elizabeth
Bank va recevoir les syndicats demain et
dans une interview Journal du Dimanche
elle dit qu'elle veut faire plus de
place à la négociation et un dialogue
social vous y croyez je l'espère c'est
je crois important parce qu'on voit
effectivement
le sujet et la question sociale qui
s'est posée sur cette réforme des
retraites mais on voit aussi
l'impact démocratique on le voit
aujourd'hui au Parlement à l'exception
de quelques textes dans celui que vous
venez d'évoquer et sur les feux de forêt
particulièrement utiles on voit que
depuis cette réforme plus rien ne se
passe ou presque puisque tous les grands
textes ont été renvoyés comme le texte
sur l'immigration on attend le texte sur
le sur le travail et cela commence à
devenir un petit peu inquiétant dans un
pays qui a grand besoin au contraire
d'avancer sur sur tous ces sujets donc
j'espère que cette concertation
cet échange avec les syndicats produira
des effets positifs on le disait la
dernière fois lorsque j'étais ici même
invité malheureusement rien ne s'est
passé ou presque et donc il faut
maintenant que les choses puissent
puissent avancer sur ce sujet on va
revenir sur le Parlement mais sur la
réforme des retraites vous vous êtes
abstenus oui sur la réforme des
retraites lors du vote au Sénat alors
que votre groupe a voté cette réforme
est-ce que vous souhaitez que la
proposition de loi d'abrogation de la
réforme présentée par liotte passe mais
je crois que aujourd'hui je peux pas
mettre absolu sur un considérant qui
était le fait qu'on est utilisé un
véhicule législatif à savoir le projet
de loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
rectificative et se dire que ce texte
peut se jouer sur une proposition de loi
comme le groupe lot je crois que c'est
un sujet suffisamment important pour
qu'on aille beaucoup plus au fond c'est
ce que j'ai regretté sur sur la forme je
pense que c'est un sujet suffisamment
essentiel pour qu'on lui donne j'allais
dire une portée et donc et donc des
échanges au Parlement qui soient plus
importants donc on va voir ce que vont
donner les négociations mais moi
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir maintenant
avancer sur sur le fond pour vous la
page du Parlement est tourné place au
syndicat et négociations entre Élisabeth
borne aujourd'hui c'est d'urgence qu'il
faut réinstaller le dialogue social qui
a à mon sens trop manqué contrairement à
ce qui a pu nous dire le gouvernement
sur le Parlement Elizabeth borne elle
dit que le Parlement n'est pas empêché
de travailler qu'il n'est pas bloqué qui
a des textes qui sont adoptés 27
dit-elle elle a tort
on peut quantifier le nombre de textes
après c'est ce que je vous disais à
l'instant il faut regarder
quels sont quels sont ces textes bien
sûr qu'il y a des sujets intéressants
mais on voit bien les difficultés on va
parler dans quelques instants de la
question de la sécurité la question de
l'autorité de l'État la question du
travail ce sont ces thèmes majeurs dont
le Parlement doit se saisir et je pense
que malheureusement l'écueil dans lequel
nous sommes tombés avec la façon
d'avancer sur la réforme des retraites
gel en tout cas bloc les travaux du
Parlement bien sûr qu'il y a
l'initiative parlementaire et nous
l'avons fait vous venez d'en faire la
démonstration sur la question des
incendies et des feux de forêts mais on
voit bien qu'il y a besoin que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui nous donne des
un cap sa lecture sur ces mesures de
réformer c'est ce que vous dites il est
en mesure de faire passer certains
textes et plus de réformer que sa
majorité relative à l'Assemblée le
pénalisent lourdement on va parler de la
protection des élus des violences envers
les élus puisque la démission du maire
de Saint-Brevin a remis le dossier sur
la table obligé de démissionner de
quitter sa commune il dénonce un manque
de soutien de l'État vous partagez ça
je considère que trop nombreuses et
nombreuses sont les élus qui sont
exposés à des violences et qui attendent
désespérément des réponses qui ne
viennent pas le maire de Saint-Brevin
malheureusement n'est pas le premier
confronté à ce sujet on a eu l'épisode
du maire de Bron avec la voiture qui a
été fortement dégradée le maire de
Briançon et tant d'autres je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est urgent de
restaurer cette autorité de l'État
nécessaire pour que celles et ceux qui
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
parce qu'il faut le redire le maire il
est avant tout dépositaire de l'autorité
publique ne soit pas aussi exposée
qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui et on parle
de maire qui ont des communes d'une
taille significative je rappelle qu'en
France c'est 17000 communes de moins de
500 habitants un maire d'une commune de
500 habitants n'a absolument pas les
moyens de faire face aujourd'hui aux
violences quelles qu'elles soient parce
qu'il y a les violences physiques c'est
l'exemple du maire de Saint-Brévin avec
des actes criminel mais il y a aussi des
violences peut-être moins moins visibles
mais qui sont de l'ordre du harcèlement
on a beaucoup parlé de la question des
réseaux sociaux ou les élus sont
considérablement aujourd'hui exposés il
va falloir trouver aussi des réponses à
tous ces sujets qui sont des sujets un
petit peu nouveaux qui appellent aussi
une réflexion sur la liberté
d'expression sur tout ce qui participe
bien sûr du débat et de la vie
démocratique mais il ne faut pas fermer
les yeux sur l'impact que ça sur des
mers hommes et femmes qui se trouvent
complètement exposé et menacé parfois
par cette violence et on va y venir et
on va venir sur les réponses et les
travaux du Sénat que vous avez souvent
vous-même mené le maire de Saint-Brévin
sera reçu par le Sénat on va en parler
mais il sera également reçu par
Elisabeth borne est-ce que cette
démission aura le mérite d'une prise de
conscience de la part du gouvernement
pour vous je l'espère je l'espère mais
je redoute que on tourne la page trop
vite vous savez je réfléchissais à ce
sujet depuis que l'acte a été commis il
n'est pas rare que les questions
d'actualité se succèdent appelant
responsabilité sur le sujet du
gouvernement rappelant tous les faits de
violence auquel les différents maires de
France ont été confrontés donc j'espère
pardon réponse et malheureusement avec
des réponses trop timides je ne dis pas
qu'il y a pas eu de réponse je pense que
les réponses ne sont pas là hauteur du
besoin et des attentes vous-même vous
avez déjà été menacé menacée non mais
j'ai été exposé j'ai été maire pendant
pendant 9 ans parfois une forme de de
violence un peu plus sourde ou
à des formes comme je le disais de
harcèlement sur certains projets parce
que les concitoyens ne s'y retrouvent
pas or la vie démocratique c'est pouvoir
exprimer une opinion sans dépasser la
limite et tomber dans des formes
protégées suffisamment soutenu alors moi
j'étais maire d'une commune qui faisait
plus de 10000 habitants on est peut-être
plus entouré que quand je le disais
quand on est maire d'une commune de
moins de 500 habitants mais on reçoit
toujours mal les critiques quand elles
sont trop quand elles basculent parfois
dans une forme de violence on va voir ce
que fait le Sénat qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur ces questions depuis des
années on voit ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Oriane bonjour
Mathieu d'Arnaud bonjour et Alex le
Sénat travaille donc depuis plusieurs
années sur ces questions de violences
faites aux élus effectivement notamment
des 2019 après la mort du maire de
signes dans le département du Var Jean
Mathieu Michel un maire qui est décédé
après avoir après être intervenu envers
une camionnette qui faisait du dépôt de
gravats sauvage le Sénat avait alors
lancé une grande consultation à des
maires sur les violences faites aux élus
10% des mers avaient répondu et résultat
et bien 92% des maires à l'époque
affirmés déjà avoir été victime de
violence verbales ou physiques au terme
de ces travaux à l'époque les sénateurs
avaient fait des propositions dont
certaines avaient été reprises dans une
loi en 2019 la loi engagement et
proximité ce texte renforcé le pouvoir
de police des mers et élargit la
protection fonctionnelle des mers un
système d'assurance spécifique financé
par la collectivité autre avancer
législatives apportées par les
ordinateur sur ce sujet la possibilité
pour les associations d'élus de se
constituer partie civile en cas
d'agression d'un élu dans le cadre de
ses fonctions c'est une mesure qui a été
permise par la proposition de loi écrite
par la signatrice de Gironde Nathalie
Delattre et voté par le Parlement en
2022 et puis à l'automne dernier les
sénateurs ont voté dans la loi
d'orientation du ministère de
l'Intérieur un durcissement de la peine
encourue en cas de violence contre les
élus pour la porter à 50 prisons et
75000 euros d'amende c'est à dire au
même niveau qu'en cas de violence contre
un policier ou un pompier une mesure qui
a été votée par le Parlement mais elle a
été retoquée par le Conseil
constitutionnel car les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel estiment qu'elle n'avait
rien à faire dans un texte d'orientation
du ministère de l'Intérieur donc cette
mesure est appelée à être réintégrée
dans un autre texte peut-être la réforme
de la justice à venir ou alors une
proposition de loi seule les sénateurs
souhaitent donc actuellement durcir les
peines sur ces violences faites aux élus
et certains estiment qu'il faut aussi
agir en amont de ces violences on va
écouter le sénateur centriste Louis
kervé qui lui aussi lorsqu'il était
maire a été victime de menaces de mort
on l'écoute je pense qu'il y a des
mesures de prévention et que on peut pas
quand une situation se est délétère et
ce cristallise sur une personne ou dans
une commune faut pas attendre que le
domicile lumière soit incendié et il
faut pas attendre que le maire
démissionne monsieur d'Arnaud on va
évoquer le durcissement des peines pour
ce type de violence mais d'abord une
réaction est-ce qu'il faut aussi agir en
amont faire de la prévention pour éviter
ces violences faites aux élus et par
exemple avoir plus d'interdictions
administratives de certaines
manifestations de groupuscules qui
voudraient mettre la pression sur les
élus c'est ce que demander justement
dans cette affaire le maire de
Saint-Brévin mais le préfère fuser
d'interdire les manifestations bien
évidemment et d'ailleurs je le disais
tout à l'heure mais beaucoup de des
actes criminels qui ont été commis
malheureusement
pouvait déjà donner lieu à quelques
signes avant-coureurs on l'a vu avec le
maire de Saint-Brevin puisque lui-même
avait appelé
à l'aide par rapport au service de au
service de l'État on a vu que beaucoup
malheureusement d'actes se répétaient
sur sur des élus donc oui bien sûr qu'il
faut en amont des actes il faut pouvoir
accompagner ces mères qui se trouvent je
le disais totalement démunie devant des
situations de violence comme celle qu'on
a connu imaginez incendie un domicile un
véhicule vous imaginez la violence que
cela représente pour pour un élu
j'allais dire pour chacune et chacun de
nos concitoyens c'est déjà le cas mais
un élu qui se trouve exposé de par ces
mandats je trouve que c'est quelque
chose de particulièrement grave qui
ramène comme je le disais tout à l'heure
à la question de l'autorité de l'État et
puis il faut pouvoir
être à l'écoute des mers nous étions
avec la mission d'information il y a
quelques jours dans la Somme d'abord
rencontrer le procureur de la République
je crois qu'il y a des initiatives qui
sont intéressantes qui sont en train
d'être développés le fait par exemple de
mettre à disposition une adresse mail
dédié pour que chaque élu puisse rentrer
en contact avec le procureur pour lui
faire remonter ce type d'acte qu'il
subisse et puis le procureur a mis en
place
j'ai dire cette cellule avec une
personne dédiée pour traiter chacune de
ces de ces remontées qui est
malheureusement
viennent
j'allais dire considérablement troublé
la vie de ses élus à moi puisque vous
parliez d'écoutes vous allez recevoir le
maire de Saint-Brévin dans la semaine
ici au Sénat qu'est-ce que vous attendez
je crois déjà installé un échange pour
pouvoir clairement
identifier les différentes étapes
successives montrer là où l'État a pu
faillir là où il y a eu un manque
d'écoute et justement essayer à la fois
de réfléchir à la façon dont on peut
mieux anticiper c'est ce que vous disiez
à l'instant et puis surtout trouver les
réponses adaptées pour que ces élus ne
se retrouvent pas considérablement seul
face à ces difficultés alors je le
disais à l'automne dernier les sénateurs
ont voté un durcissement des peines pour
les auteurs de ces violences faites aux
élus pour des raisons techniques la
mesure a été retoquée vous souhaitez
qu'elle soit remise sur la table
rapidement oui bien sûr parce que je
pense que il y a la prévention il y a
l'accompagnement et puis il y a la peine
ce sont des actes terriblement graves on
incendie pas le domicile
d'une personne ni d'un élu c'est
absolument inconcevable ça met
une partie de la vie démocratique locale
comment voulez-vous inviter nos
concitoyens à s'engager à prendre place
dans le débat public si
ce type d'événement se succède donc je
pense qu'il faut une réponse rapide il
faut que l'État réaffirme son autorité
et notamment son autorité pour mieux
accompagner les femmes et les hommes qui
s'engagent dans la vie publique et qui
sont qui deviennent de par leur mandat
dépositaire de l'autorité publique donc
selon vous c'est aussi le signe d'une
perte de l'autorité de l'État et des
élus des pouvoirs publics dans notre
société complètement je pense que les
élus n'échappent pas la violence de la
société ils sont peut-être même en
première ligne et la réponse doit être à
la hauteur de ces faits qui sont encore
une fois graves la première réponse du
gouvernement c'est la création d'un
centre de lutte contre les violences
faites aux élus c'est utile pour vous
c'est la bonne réponse c'est utile mais
ça ne suffira pas je pense qu'il faut
absolument renforcer l'échelle des
peines vous l'avez rappelé et moi je
j'espère qu'on reviendra assez
rapidement dessus j'ai cru comprendre
que le gouvernement il réfléchissait
aussi et puis encore une fois il faut
une proximité entre justice et élue
entre les procureurs de la République et
les élus pour installer aussi un
dialogue permanent pour peut-être mieux
identifier
ce qui peut devenir un fait délictueux
grave et qu'il y ait un accompagnement
je pense que c'est essentiel parce
qu'encore une fois je le dis mais j'ai
senti chez certains élus une détresse
absolue il ne savent pas vers qui se
tourner ils craignent pour leur propre
je veux dire intégrité l'intégrité de
leur famille et il se trouve exposé et
dans une détresse absolue donc il faut
absolument les accompagner et qui peut
aboutir à quoi est-ce que vous craignez
il y a des municipales alors c'est dans
longtemps c'est en 2026 mais est-ce que
vous craignez un manque de candidat
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la démocratie
locale est en danger quelque part oui je
le je le redoute parce que pour avoir
vous rappeler
les différents textes notamment
engagement et proximité j'en étais le
Cora porteur avec Françoise Gatel
j'étais avec Philippe Bas à l'origine de
la concertation que nous avions lancée
suite à la mort du maire de signe dans
le Var on voyait déjà un premier signe
j'allais dire avant-coureur d'un
désengagement parfois d'une forme de
détresse des des élus qui ne cessent de
ce de ce renforcer et quand on écoute on
a fait plusieurs déplacements dans les
départements nous avons été en
Ille-et-Vilaine dans la Somme dans les
Vosges en Haute-Garonne donc dans des
départements très très différents des
territoires urbains des territoires
ruraux et finalement la tonalité et la
même les élus se désespèrent de ne pas
être mieux accompagné de ne pas être
parfois compris dans la détresse qui est
la leur je disais il n'y a pas que les
violences physiques il y a aussi cette
violence sur les réseaux sociaux
cette forme de harcèlement dont ils sont
victimes par rapport à des projets par
rapport à
l'exercice de leur mandat et la
traduction est toujours la même c'est de
dire que il ne se représenteront pas et
je vais même plus loin qu'il ne
termineront pas pour beaucoup leur
mandat je rappelle quand même qu'on est
pour la première fois depuis 2020 sur un
nombre de démission des mers record nous
arrivons à plus de 1200 démissions de
mer et ça
ce n'est que les mers on a quasiment
chaque semaine dans des départements des
élections partielles car des élus
municipaux conseillers municipaux
adjoints démissionnent alors pas que
pour des faits de violence mais en
partie parce que ils ne se retrouve plus
dans l'exercice de leur mandat et qu'ils
ont affaire à trop de difficultés et de
contraintes merci
on parlera de l'interview fleuve
d'Emmanuel Macron dans le journal
l'opinion et vous nous direz toute cette
interview merci Alex à tout à l'heure
actualités dans votre département
la relation on retrouve Carole Raynaud à
Valence chef d'information pour la de la
Drôme Ardèche à la rédaction du Dauphiné
Libéré bonjour Carole merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on commence par la
Drôme puisque vous revenez sur les
règlements de compte qui ont frappé
Valence ces derniers jours
et oui trois meurtres en quatre jours
c'est du jamais vu c'est une violence
inouïe sur Valence
et puis c'est vrai que ce qui s'est
passé c'est que le dernier meurtre se
rapproche un peu plus du centre-ville
donc les Valentinois ont peur ça fait
quoi est-ce que dit le sénateur d'Arnaud
sur les difficultés des élus aussi tous
les jours à gérer cette délinquance moi
j'avais vraiment une question pour lui
parce que
comment faire quel rôle Almer puisqu'il
est le premier contact de ces
administrés en l'occurrence le maire de
Valence Nicolas d'Aragon le maire et
l'air plaid et demande du renfort de
l'État actuellement il y a plus d'une
centaine d'hommes en renfort sur sur
Valence mais pour combien de temps
finalement quel rôle le maire peut faire
dans un contexte aussi violent que
celui-ci donc on va revenir là dessus
tout au long de la semaine on suit le
dispositif en Suisse en quête monsieur
le sénateur qu'est-ce que vous dites que
peut faire le maire face à ça est-ce que
dans les travaux que vous venez cette
question de la délinquance et récurrente
je crois qu'elle fait écho à la au sujet
qu'on vient d'aborder
l'autorité de l'État je connais bien
Valence ma commune fait face à Valence
je suis conseiller municipal à
Guilherand-Granges je connais très bien
Nicolas d'Aragon c'est un collègue et un
ami je sais qu'il aujourd'hui
désespèrent un peu de l'absence de
réponse de l'État il a sollicité à
plusieurs reprises le ministre de
l'Intérieur la première ministre il a
dit qu'il attendait
urgemment des réponses on a un renfort
cela vient d'être évoqué notamment avec
des compagnies de CRS mais c'est un
renfort qui
ne durera pas et ce qui est très
symptomatique c'est que le troisième
meurtre s'est produit en dehors du
périmètre qui était protégé par les CRS
donc on voit bien toute la fragilité de
ces dispositifs et on voit bien combien
le maire encore une fois il est démuni
j'ai eu à entendre à écouter à partager
ce qui se passe avec avec nombreuses et
nombreux de Valentinois et
malheureusement effectivement il se
tourne très souvent vers le maire mais
rappelons que c'est une compétence la
sécurité de l'État je le dis je le
répète et les mesures qui ont été prises
par le gouvernement en singulièrement
par le ministre de l'intérieur
par rapport à un renfort de policiers
500 pour notamment les 200 villes
moyennes ça fait deux policiers et demi
pour une commune comme Valence on voit
bien que c'est largement insuffisant je
pense qu'il faut une action plus en
profondeur on voit bien que certains
quartiers sont considérablement exposés
et que les maires qui sont
particulièrement investis parce qu'ils
sont en première ligne n'ont pas
capacité à répondre à eux seuls donc il
faut restaurer cette autorité de l'État
la sécurité c'est la première des
libertés on ne le dira jamais assez et
il faut que les mères et le sentiment
d'être accompagnés qu'ils aient un rôle
à jouer c'est inévitable parce qu'encore
une fois ils sont face
préoccupations ils doivent faire face
aux préoccupations de leurs concitoyens
mais quand ils n'ont pas la compétence
il est prérogative alors il se tournent
justement vers l'état et la moindre des
choses c'est que l'État renvoie des
signaux forts parce qu'on ne peut pas
admettre qu'en 4 jours dans une commune
de 66000 habitants il y ait un épisode
aussi violent que celui que vienne de
connaître les valentinoises et les
Valentinois
l'AR
dèche sécheresse qui pousse les
autorités à prendre de nouvelles mesures
oui vous le savez il a bu ces derniers
jours mais ce n'est pas suffisant ça
remplit pas du tout les nappes
phréatiques du pull département de
l'Ardèche étant très grande vigilance en
Harley te renforcer sur certains de ces
de ces cours d'eau le préfet de
l'Ardèche a dû prendre des dispositions
et interdit sur certaines communes
carrément de prendre des permis de
construire alors ça peut concerner des
maisons simplement des piscines on
l'entend mais là encore finalement la
frustré n'a pas forcément connaissance
de tout ça et c'est le maire qui refuse
au bout du bout permis de construire à
ces nouveaux habitants il passe un petit
peu pour le méchant de service il va
falloir faire preuve de pédagogie ce
sont des dispositifs qui sont
temporaires sur certaines communes déjà
les tailles est revenu en arrière
puisqu'il y a eu des travaux justement
pour pour
rénover le système d'irrigation pour
éviter des fuites mais c'est vrai que
l'Ardèche fait partie des des
départements vraiment sous vigilance
pour le maintien de cette ressource en
eau
est-ce que ça sera la solution ça se
fait un petit peu au fil en fait des
de la météo et puis du contexte
géographique là encore
c'est le territoire qui qui doit avoir
le dernier mot sur sur cette thématique
c'est un sujet que je connais bien pour
m'y investir considérablement ici au
Sénat on a mené avec la délégation à la
prospective on a commis un rapport pour
mettre en évidence justement ces
problématiques je regrette un petit peu
que les mers soient en première ligne
sur un sujet comme celui-ci je le dis
parce que finalement et vous l'avez
justement rappelé c'est eux qui se
trouve face à nos concitoyens or ces
interdictions de délivrance de permis de
construire sont aussi des limites au
développement de la commune je pense
notamment aux activités économiques on a
eu un exemple sur la sur la commune de
Vallon-Pont-d'Arc mais plus encore je
pense qu'il faut accompagner ces
communes prendre des mesures
j'allais dire de limitation ou de refus
de délivrance c'est une chose maintenant
il faut que l'État encore une fois
puisque c'est une de ses compétences
mettent les moyens notamment sur ces
fameux réseaux fuyard c'est à dire sur
cette perte en ligne je sais que le
département de l'Ardèche et j'assistais
la dernière fois un renforcement de
réseau d'irrigation sur la plaine de
Chomérac mais des moyens mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin et je
m'inquiète je le dis parce que quand je
vois la présentation du plan o par le
gouvernement qui met un peu plus de 100
millions sur les réseaux fuyard sans
mauvais jeu de mots c'est une goutte
d'eau par rapport aux besoins que l'on a
singulièrement sur des territoires comme
le nôtre qui comme vous l'avez dit sont
particulièrement exposés donc il faut
aller plus loin dans l'accompagnement de
ces communes par rapport aux travaux
qu'elle doit faire par rapport à cette
question de la sobriété de l'économie en
eau mais aussi d'un accompagnement
financier je le dis très solennellement
l'eau c'est une des problématiques
auxquelles tout nos territoires et je
dis bien tout nos territoires qu'ils
soient au sud ou au Nord vont être
confrontés demain c'est un enjeu et un
défi considérable pour un pays comme la
France et il faudra que l'État soit au
rendez-vous il faut restaurer ce
principe
affirmé mé que l'eau paylo mais il faut
aller plus loin dans l'accompagnement
financière des territoires merci
d'avoir été avec nous la une du Dauphiné
au cœur du périlleux travail des
démineurs c'est à la Une de votre
journal aujourd'hui merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de cette
actualité et merci beaucoup Mathieu
barnot merci à vous d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin merci